please tell us why nfts are so important
look man nfts aren't just the weight of
the future they are the future all right
different economy different Workforce
different art nothing will be the same
again because of nfts okay how do you
respond to well first off there's a
recent uh viral video sort of tearing
apart nfts and cryptocurrencies have you
heard of it no uh would you like to
watch it just give me the
phone um what did you think well just
stupid right it's just dumb just really
stupid thank you for wasting my time
anyways we were talking about what
artificial intelligence yes no we were
talking about nfts well let's talk about
AI because uh AI isn't just the way to
the Future it is the future